alors effectivement vous le voyez
derrière moi c'est un accident de
transport scolaire qui a eu lieu ce
matin aux alentours de 9h sur cette
route entre la d re je mens et
saint-antoine à bord de ce bus est bien
une trentaine d'enfants dont trois sont
enregistrés comme des blessés graves
alors il ya un peu moins d'une heure
désormais une jeune fille une
adolescente a été désincarcéré du bus
une opération qui a duré environ 40
minutes
elle est polytraumatisée dans un état
grave mais ses jours ne sont pas en
danger elle est restée consciente tout
pendant l'opération diligentée par la
trentaine de pompiers qui ont été
dépêchés sur place alors il a été
transporté directement au chu de
besançon par voie terrestre et non pas
par hélicoptère parce que les conditions
climatiques ne le permettent pas un
autre jeune garçon lui a été dirigé vers
l'hôpital de pontarlier pour les 30
autres enfants et bien ils ont été
directement acheminés vers une salle à
labergement sainte marie où a été dressé
un accueil médico psychologique avec une
cellule d'écouté un petit déjeuner aussi
et ils ont pu pour certains retrouver
leurs parents
voilà pour le bilan de cet accident qui
fait écho dans les mémoires évidemment à
celui qui avait eu lieu en 2016 à mon
flow 20 qui avait occasionné la mort de
deux adolescents qui aussi se rendait au
collège voilà c'était la première neige
de cet hiver est donc le premier
accident de l'hiver